[Música]
me han golpeado toda mi vida mi cuerpo
se acostumbró
las llamaremos milán a esta en sus 30
años es originaria de chechenia una
pequeña república musulmana del sur de
rusia con un sistema patriarcal y
costumbres anticuadas
dirigida con mano dura por ramzán
kadyrov protegido de vladimir putin
kadyrov aboga por la poligamia la
sumisión de las mujeres y reprime toda
libertad de expresión
milan a permanecer anónima porque en su
país su historia es un tabú
es privado
esta cicatriz es la marca de la hebilla
de un cinturón cuando mi papá me pegaba
aquí apago un cigarrillo y esta es la
marca de un golpe con un palo porque
siempre me acosaba y me tocaba donde
está prohibido cuando estaba borracho y
yo no podía decirle a nadie porque tenía
miedo de avergonzar a mi familia y
apoyado después
la vergüenza es lo que llegó a milán a
huir de chechenia e irse a este refugio
teme por su vida desde que fue violada
por un agente de seguridad checheno que
la grabo y la chantajeó con el vídeo
mis papás me hubieran matado y si no
hubieran sido mis papás entonces lo
habrían hecho mis tíos mis primos en
nuestro clan seguramente hubiera habido
un hombre que me matara la palabra
víctima no existe en nuestra cultura una
mujer siempre tiene la culpa para apoyar
sus declaraciones milana nos muestra los
reportajes emitidos por la televisión
pública chechena sesiones en las que se
humillan a las mujeres dirigidas
personalmente por ramzán kadyrov que las
acusa de los llamados crímenes de honor
no te da vergüenza por tu hermano mira
tu peinado por tu culpa a la gente habla
de su mujer dicen que frecuenta los
cafés por culpa de mujeres así hay
tantos divorcios y decenas cientos de
hombres en prisión cientos de crímenes
de honor
para nosotros si una mujer tiene la
culpa convocan a todo su clan le dicen
al hombre eres un hombre no así que
resuelve los problemas con tu hermana o
te casas con ella o
[Música]
por su ambición porque no hay nadie que
la calma porque no hay un hombre que la
ponga en su lugar como esta loca en esta
cuerda se le debió haber leído el corán
decirle oye qué haces tú que eres su
hermano si te estoy hablando a ti
deberías haber calmado tu hermana
el pasado 23 de junio ramsan kadyrov
arremetió contra la madre de una mujer
de 23 años
tras acusar al marido de su hija de
haberla matado a golpes unos días antes
hizo es sumar su cuerpo para una
autopsia
kadyrov curioso porque esto contradice
su visión del islam ordenó que se le
devolvieran los hijos al presunto
asesino que no tendrá otro juicio más
que éste aunque que la zona han quitado
que volveremos a tus hijas yo me
encargaré de sus necesidades
construiré una casa haré todo por ellas
un mes después la televisión chechena
mostraba a la familia política mudándose
a su nueva casa es este tipo de
impunidad la que obliga a las mujeres
chechenas a sufrir en silencio la mujer
en grozny la capital este refugio les
ofrece un hogar temporal su misión
principal es mediar para que regresen
con sus familias
así es como tradicionalmente regulamos
las relaciones dentro de la familia
nuestra autoridad religiosa se encarga
antes que nada de los asuntos familiares
nuestro primer objetivo no es tanto
defender los derechos de la mujer como
proteger el futuro de los niños
intentamos asegurarnos de que el niño
conserve a ambos padres y de trastorno
de trastorno
según la tradición chechena en caso de
divorcio la familia del padre se queda
con los niños cuando preguntamos sobre
la posición de ramzán kadyrov acerca de
estos temas la conversación se detuvo
por completo
detengan eso por favor no se tiene que
hablar de eso no se tiene que hablar de
ramzán akhmadovich
[Música]
para hablar abiertamente debemos irnos
de chechenia hacia la vecina república
de ingushetia los llamados crímenes de
honor son perpetrados en gran parte del
cáucaso ruso como socióloga y
especialista en género zaida estudia de
cerca este fenómeno la explosión de los
crímenes de honor es un fenómeno
relativamente reciente está ligado sobre
todo al neo tradicionalismo es decir al
intento de revivir viejas tradiciones
reinterpretando las ha interpretado
expongo forma
para salida los llamados crímenes de no
son mucho más numerosos que los 50 casos
que ha podido confirmar esta es una
peculiaridad de nuestra región cuando
hay un crimen la sociedad no dice nada
en la mayoría de los casos incluso las
madres tratan de ocultar la tragedia
porque dependen de la comunidad y de
otros miembros de la familia
sería bueno que fuéramos escuchadas así
si hubiera una institución de apoyo que
no dependa de nuestro dirigente ni
atrapada en un refugio en algún lugar de
rusia milán a sueña con la libertad de
expresión mientras mira los programas
rusos donde las víctimas de violencia
doméstica se expresan abiertamente
actualmente en chechenia hacemos como si
todo estuviera bien pero en cada familia
hay mujeres como yo que sufren a quienes
les pegan sus papás quienes no tienen
derecho a hacer nada ni siquiera a salir
de casa
dejando atrás el peso de la tradición
milana se enfrenta a un futuro incierto